when you choose to work through those
things they actually you know I feel
like now that I've worked through a lot
of that stuff you and I are closer than
ever yeah I agree
Justin and Haley beaver just dropped the
first episode of their 12 part Facebook
watch series the beavers on watch from
their past breakup to tying the knot
they're opening up like never before
there's a lot of things that I needed to
work on hmm
forgiveness things jealousy things
insecurities I chose to make the whole
thing was filmed by Justin and Haley
themselves the two are quarantined in
Toronto where Justin grew up now we are
breaking down the 7 biggest bombshells
from their lakeside lovers chat starting
with this he's a good kid it's a good
heart and I love that Haley gets real
about the heartbreak she felt when they
broke up back in 2016 she explained why
she didn't rush to be in another
relationship immediately after I really
let myself feel the emotions that I was
feeling you know it took a lot of it
feels like grieving when you feel like
you lose it is creeping actually doesn't
feel like greeting it is grouping you
you lose yeah like something left that
you really really love and care about
and even though she was going through it
she just hoped one day they'd be able to
be friends I should remember I was like
I I cared about you so much that I was
like it doesn't even matter to me if
he's in my life in like a romantic way
just like to care about so much that
I want him to like I want us to be in
each other's lives and would that be
okay in the end Haley said the breakup
was actually one of the best things that
ever happened to them why well she says
she did a lot of work on herself and by
the time they got back together things
were different in a good way I had
experience to other people where I was
just like yeah I'm cool if I never like
speak to another human again like
another guy again it didn't matter to me
after their split Justin briefly got
back together with his ex Selena Gomez
Jesus like it was easy
yeah Haley kinda sorta talked about that
too people will say to me like before
comment and like on the internet and
everything oh he did this or he was with
this person or that person or whatever
and it's just like you have to step into
a security especially as a wife to be
like I'm aware of everything you're
saying I think that that's where
forgiveness is the biggest thing during
their time apart Haley says that their
mutual friends kept her in the loop on
how he was doing you know they would
tell me that you know we're working
really working on yourself and you were
doing really well
they had been really impressed by how
many were living your life and you know
you were trying to keep to yourself
you weren't like you weren't on any like
if I am allowed to say this you weren't
on anything anymore
and while the couple has never really
gone into details of what prompted that
split Hayley previously told Jimmy
Fallon that it was that moment on The
Tonight Show in 2018 that helped the
couple turn things back on the next
morning after the interview had aired
I got a certain phone call from a
certain someone and it was a little like
hey how are you I saw you on Jimmy
Fallon last night you were looking
really good I loved that trick that you
did I had no idea that you can do that
it was so cool
cut to I'm now married to that certain
zone I mean can we blame him that really
was an epic party trick and I have this
thing he's checking the game she's so
awesome anyway that late-night
appearance was in May 2018 in July they
confirmed they were engaged on Instagram
and in September they tied the knot in a
New York City courthouse
since I was young I always like wanted
to be married I always wanted a family
that was always high on my list but
Justin and Haley said they put in the
work to get their relationship on track
it takes a lot of work when you say like
people yeah obviously you've had to work
hard on our relationship and I think
that that pays off in a way where you
just become so connected to each other
yeah so
close and so just solid with each other
I mean obviously you're my best friend
so I think that's like the biggest
payoff is you have a best friend that
you can just do everything with these
two really do seem like besties and I
love it it's just really fun to just
experience new things if you travel with
you yeah Justin gives hailey a big
shoutout for standing by him when he was
going through it you make a covenant
before God to love that person for
better for worse in sickness and in
health which is something that you've
done amazing for me you were there when
I was really struggling and I'm this
season where I feel like the closest
we've ever been
the couple's new series comes after
Justin's docu-series Justin Bieber
seasons which launched in January
chronicling the singer's life and making
of his latest album changes back in the
studio
cutting the song keep on forgiving me
this one over here hailey she just every
time I do something stupid she forgives
me so there's that et sat down with the
docu-series director Michael D Ratner in
February he opened up about Justin's
decision to share his life with the
world I'll tell you one line that he
said to me that has stuck with me
forever unless we watched episode 5
together and he was just staring at it
and he's like this is tough and he said
there's power and weakness and I thought
when he said that you know he said the
very reasons why it's sometimes
uncomfortable for me to watch that as
the reasons I went out there